guys this is the real voice of elizabeth
holmes
who had been faking a deep baritone
while following silicon valley to the
tune of 10
billion dollars which we're talking
about today check it out no it hasn't
well
if i use traditional words oh the two
octave
switch baby no it hasn't
well if i use traditional words no
it hasn't well if i choose it guys
that's the level
of sociopath we're dealing with in
silicon valley and she's not the only
one but we're gonna learn from her
today we're gonna take some big old
lessons uh
in a new series i'm calling silicon
valley scammers ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host
coffee zilla and today of course we're
taking a look at elizabeth holmes
you know her you probably have heard of
her she's one of the most famous
examples of how hey us
normal people not in silicon valley
we're not the only dum-dums listen
there's dumb money everywhere it's a
fact of life
right it's not just you know uh people
in lower economic circumstances there's
dumb money everywhere and it comes from
different places
some you know a lot of people we talk
about the fake gurus they're preying on
desperate dumb money but there's also a
type of dumb money
which is different it's where you have
like affluent people
in silicon valley and it's i call it
greedy dumb money right you can get dumb
in a lot of ways but those are the two
primary
you have desperate dumb money and greedy
dumb money
i feel a little less bad for this one
but it's still funny and worth checking
out
but it's important to say listen there's
a lot of smart investors
in silicon valley but the problem is
y'all are a little cocky
in silicon valley and sometimes you
think hey we're just gonna apply
like revolutionize the industry to every
industry they think like they got a
little cocky because they got us with
the computer
right they got us with airbnb you know
admittingly you've had a few successes
so you're getting cocky over there and
then you're like hey let's
what uh i don't know what do i have on
my desk
nice the thin mint right like ai thin
mints how do we revolutionize
the mug how do we everything has to be
revolutionized
so uh this was taken to blood testing
right and there was a young woman named
elizabeth
holmes who took the silicon valley world
by
storm when she came out and she said hey
i've got the new solution i'm the next
steve jobs and you can even see it in
the way she dresses listen a lot of
these people
they worship they have alters to steve
jobs in their home
and they all dress like him but that's
not the point of this video the point is
elizabeth holmes comes on scene she's a
19 year old dropout
from stanford uh chemical engineering i
think which is
yeah i mean you can't trust a chemical
engineer as far as you can throw them
trust me guys okay and so she comes on
and she you know what she did right
because i mean this video is more about
the psychology of how people got skipped
she played into all the prejudices of
silicon valley like the crazy backstory
of a dropout who's
gonna revolutionize the world with her
little tech idea or his tech idea
that's a total silicon valley thing that
they just fawn over right
and then the ted talk or like the
wannabe ted talk this is ted med
silicon valley just like you show a ted
talk
i mean they they write an empty check
like how much do you want
we'll give you whatever you want and and
then the cadence oh
i love this stuff look at this look at
the way she talks
i believe the individual
is the answer dude like pregnant posits
every sentence
there's like 12 commas in between every
uh phrase she has
i believe comma the individual
comma comma is the answer and it's not
like that all the way through
to the challenges of health care
but we can't engage the individual
in changing what is this cadence of
speech silicon valley
you've gone too far you gave this woman
a 12 billion
or 10 billion dollar valuation how and
it's not like they've learned their
lesson
look you look at nicola right now dude
you know they at one point were worth
more than
ford and they never sold a single car i
mean like
nothing's changed it's not like oh we
found out oh she's a fraud oh so we
don't invest in frauds anymore dude
silicon valley so much dumb money going
around over there and it's all because
you guys keep falling for con people
who you know they have vision right they
like they're like envisioning the future
the problem is
it doesn't exist like they go to their
engineers and they're like hey
can we make i had this great idea like
like you know it's like
something you'd think about when you're
stoned i had this great idea like let's
just take a tiny pin prick of blood and
do 12 000 tests on it
the engineer goes yeah we can't do that
and they think to themselves i'm steve
jobs so i'll just throw them in a room
and just like let them figure it out
no yeah whoa and you'll be caught being
a fraud
years later i mean i really think that
this like this con
started with the same way a lot of real
silicon valley
things start which is like an idea and
then you kind of fake it till you make
it but in this case
what she was talking about wasn't
currently possible with any technology
so it just was faking it until you're
faking it and that's called
fraud taking on investors when you're
faking your technology is called
fraud but make no mistake this happens a
lot in silicon valley
have access to the information
they need to do so
[Music]
uh you could make a whole speech in the
pauses of her speech there's so much
space in here um what she does have
going for her too is she's got
that long vision i mean isn't this a
great idea
healthcare where you don't have big pin
pricks of and like 12 vials of blood
drawn yeah it's a great idea
doesn't work all the blood scientists
apparently i was reading they were like
yeah we knew that this was a fraud but
nobody really asked us like silicon
valley was just pumping money
into this startup no one bothered to ask
the scientists like whether this thing
was possible
and listen if you think don't think i'm
serious about like all you need to be
a successful fraud and silicon valley is
just like a backstory that silicon
valley believes in
check out what she named the machine
that she was running these tests on
right so she takes these like pin pricks
of blood right they take this tiny
little pin prick
and then they ran it in a machine let's
see if we can find this it's called the
edison
guys if you don't stop investing
in garbage ideas with clever little
names i'm gonna lose my mind
honestly dude look do you think the
market cap of
nicola would have been what it was if it
wasn't named nicola
like literally that's the only reason
that's the only reason
you just give silicon valley people a
clever name of some guy
that they freaking worship they lose
their mind it's like
hey i'm calling this machine the edison
every silicon valley investor
i give you all my money what it's the
edison does that that must mean it's as
innovative as edison
i'm constantly ragging on this like
because it's it's such a problem
this is how people get skimmed people
start saying they throw buzzwords around
like a.i or you know what honestly when
elon musk dies
somebody's going to create a company
called musk and then everyone's going to
buy into it or they're going to call it
like elon
and everyone's going to buy into it just
because we lionize these people and then
someone takes their name and just goes
yeah i'm calling my thing that
now uh and everyone throws money at it
it's
it's bizarre uh of course they later
realized that a lot of these
systems weren't actually doing the
testing they said they were like they
were doing testing the old-fashioned way
um so they were they were committing
fraud throughout
but i really do believe it's just a case
of you know having a
concept never having proof of concept
but ultimately the investor's not caring
they just throw money at you because
they like i don't know silicon valley
has this
disease where they think oh there's no
such thing as like real
problems with uh technology i i don't
know i don't know
it just blows my mind how could 10
billion dollars have been thrown at
something
where nothing existed it's all made up
it was all
a fraud this is the part that i don't
understand like again
it's not like we've learned from this
the company nicola
without selling a truck became worth
more
than ford the company nicola without
selling a truck
had a market cap over ford how
guys look at that markle is worth more
than four
it's because there's so much dumb money
that doesn't ever question is does this
thing
actually exist i mean this is like
gofundme garbage honestly just at a
higher level
it's it's the same crap that like
indiegogo people fall for
gofundme falls for where they have a
proof of concept that sounds great
doesn't exist
or sounds great but isn't what they're
saying it is it's just given to
investors and like that's the amazing
thing is you'd think
oh these people are so sophisticated
whatever um
but no in fact they can get just as
greedy they can get just as
um blindsided by just clever marketing
really that's what it ultimately comes
down to and this lady totally took
advantage of that
she took advantage of the founder
narrative that like every
every you know revolutionary thinker is
going to be a 19 year old
which we have to get rid of by the way
side note sorry about this
can we stop with the idea that 19 year
olds are gonna save us
please can we stop with the idea that
hey hey you know who's gonna save the
world
19 year old dropouts uh
no i don't actually think they are
what are you kidding does nobody
remember what it's like to be 19
like you're an idiot at that point and i
myself
i include myself in that category i'm
still an idiot right
i wouldn't trust myself to change the
world i would not trust
especially some dumb 19 year old right
they don't know anything how are we
trusting these guys
how we or girls or anybody like don't we
know that people get smarter as they age
they learn
more they get wiser we don't care about
that we think
and again it just goes back to like we
just have a few examples that have
totally changed the perception
of what a founder is now because you
have your mark zuckerbergs
you have your jack dorsey's like all
these basically young kids coming in
creating these tech companies that blow
up to be giants
now we think that's the norm now we
think oh well of course if medicine's
gonna get revolutionized
it's going to be some 19 year old who
fakes her own voice like
why it i'm telling you guys this this
really
heats me up if you can't tell and look
it's not just
dumb silicon valley people it's also
just everybody was kind of taken in and
it's a good lesson for
don't buy the hype if you see somebody
surrounded by
famous people but you've never kind of
heard of them you don't know what they
do
it doesn't mean you should just blindly
trust them and think oh just because
they're around
you know bill clinton and jack ma they
must be legit no
actually anyone can be fooled because
it's just sort of a ladder of fooling
because obviously bill clinton didn't do
his
diligence jack madden dude his due
diligence they just kind of looked and
they go oh this lady like
seems to be respected by a lot of
important people and those people
probably trusted her because they
thought she was respected
nobody actually took their time to
figure out wait is this actually
real uh but yeah he bought into both of
these guys buy into the same thing
check this out more fact than i want to
call in jack you founded this company 12
years ago right
tell them how old you were i was 19.
so
don't worry about the future we're in
good hands yikes
that didn't age well did it buddy didn't
age too well at all don't worry about
the future guys
we've lionized the con man we've given
10 billion dollars
to a cod man uh a cotton woman excuse me
excuse me okay excuse we don't have
enough women on the show we're to bring
more equality and representation
starting with elizabeth holmes
to the coffeezilla fraud universe again
you see
the lionization of like you're young and
you're changing the world oh yeah
young people young people are the future
yeah that's by definition true
but are they the future at 19 yeah
they're not just
i don't wait i got myself twisted up in
this analogy
my point is they're not the solution at
i guess is what i'm saying and uh
you got to be clear when you're
investing in anything this is just a
great lesson for everybody uh because if
silicon valley people fell for this
you could fall for this too the thing is
don't buy into the hype just because
it's hyped up
don't buy into this like future promises
just because it sounds like it's the
future
figure out is the technology there it's
either there or it's not it's a
like it's a binary instead people looked
at the clever marketing they looked at
this person who checked all the boxes of
like
this is the future steve jobs and she
even tried to dress like steve jobs
instead of looking does the technology
exist
nobody checked and because of that so
many people lost
a lot of money they basically just lost
their shirts
on theradose now she's basically facing
trial
on several charges um criminal charges
as well as she had a bunch of civil ones
as well and she awaits
trial so that's where we stand but i
think it's an interesting retrospective
on one of the all-time great cons in the
silicon valley universe now there's a
lot more and we'll be covering them so
let me know what you think
but i think this is a good primer
because you're going to see a lot of
recurring themes silicon valley people
they tend to fall for the same stuff
over and over again and we're going to
talk about it
so give it a like subscribe if you like
this kind of stuff and uh i'll see you
next time
wake up and smell the coffee